hello everyone today i will present
monotone complexity of spanning tree
polynomial revisited this is a joint
work with orgo
and the plan of my talk is the following
first i will say about basic
computational model
next i will describe two of our results
which are strongly exponential lower
bound existing neutron circuits and
epsilon sensitive monotone lower bond
and in the end i will talk about some
open problems
[Music]
an arithmetic circuit is a model for
computing polynomials there are
variables leveled at the bottom layer
and these are composed by addition and
multiplication gates
finally a polynomial is computed at the
top layer
here is an example of arithmetic circuit
which is computing this polynomial
the size of the circuit is the number of
gates appearing in it
a polynomial is called monotone if every
coefficient appearing in this polynomial
is non-negative
a circuit is called monotone if all the
edge level age labels square scalar
values are non-negative
a modern circuit naturally computes a
monotone polynomial here is an example
of monotone circuit which is computing
this monotone polynomial
some interesting examples of monotone
polynomial
the first polynomial is the symmetric
polynomial of degree k on n variable
and the second example is the permanent
polynomial polynomial corresponding to a
matrix of variable of dimension in cross
n
monitor circuits are universal for
computing monotone polynomials
say we have this monotone polynomial
a depth circuit can compute this
monotone polynomial by writing it
monomial by monomial
but
if this monotone polynomial has
exponential many monomers then this step
to circuit will be of size exponential
but monotone poly circuits can compute
monotone polynomials in a more
non-trivial way
consider this symmetric polynomial
for k equal to n by two this symmetric
polynomial has exponential many
monomials so depth to circuit will be of
size exponential size
if it compares the symmetric polynomial
but the symmetric polynomial has an
efficient monotone circuit
the gram here is an algebraic branching
program which is computing this
symmetric polynomial
the algebraic branching program
is a less stronger model than arithmetic
circuit and can be converted very
efficiently to a monotone circuit
on the other hand the permanent
polynomial is of n squared variables and
the lower bound for permanent polynomial
is 2 to the power omega n
the known monotone upper bound for
permanent polynomial is 2 to the power
order n log n
we are naturally interested to
understand what is the power of monotone
computation
or what is the strongest possible lower
bond
here we can show
[Music]
we ask this question is there a monotone
polynomial on n variables that has
monotone circuit lower bound of 2 to the
power omega n this kind of lower bond we
call strongly exponential lower bond
an important remark here that permanent
polynomial cannot be a candidate for
this kind of lower bond the reason is
permanent polynomial is an n squared
variable and a monotone upper bound of 2
to the power order n log n is already
known for permanent
strongly exponential lower bound against
monotone computations were known from
this works gas given 80s rajawa in 2009
srinivasan in 2019 kavanaugh kumar
rasman in 2020 and most recently rubesh
edward in 2021
but all the polynomials that have been
used in this works are in pnp which is
an algebraic analog of np
so what about polynomials in pp which is
an algebraic analog of p
valiant in 1979 and german snead in 1982
gave us polynomial families that belongs
to vp but admits exponential size lower
bond
so a natural question to ask here that
is it possible to get strongly
exponential monotone lower bound for tp
polynomials
our work here gives an affirmative
answer to this question
our first result is the following the
spanning tree polynomial defined for a
family of constant degree expander
graphs on n vertices requires monotone
circuit of size 2 to the power omega n
important remark here that the number of
variables in our polynomial is theta n
and this is the first strongly
exponential monotone lower bound for d
polynomial
so what is spanning to polynomial
informally the spanning tree polynomial
for a graph
has
all these monomers which represent
spanning tree in that graph but we are
interested in a very special kind of
spanning tree
consider this graph on three vertices
the spanning two polynomial for this
graph is this following polynomial but
here every monomial is representing a
spanning tree which is explicitly rooted
at one vertex
let's see how consider this monomial x 2
1 times 6 3 1
the spanning tree it is represent is the
following spanning 2 goes to 1 and 3
goes to 1. so this is rooted at vertex
1.
similarly the monomial x 2 3 x times 631
is representing the following spanning
tree 2 goes to 3 and 3 goes to 1 and
similarly for x 3 2 times x 2 1
but observe this monomial x 1 2 x 6 3 2
is not included in our spanning tree
despite it will give you a
spinning tree in the graph example let's
see what is the spanning tree the
standing tree here is 1 goes to 2 and 3
goes to 2
but this is rooted at vertex 2. so that
is why it is not included in our
polynomial
we are interested here in checking
spanning to polynomial corresponding to
a bi directed graph g on n vertices what
is a bi directed graph
a bi-directed a graph is called
bi-directed if for any two vertex set we
need two vertices i comma j if we want
to give an edge between them we need to
give two edges between them one directed
from i to j another directed from j to i
now observe here every spanning tree
monomial is giving you a map the map is
the following for this monomial x 2 1
times x 3 1 the map that we can see here
is 2 goes to 1 and 3 goes to 1.
similarly for this monomial x 2 3 time x
3 1 the map is 2 goes to 3 and 3 goes to
1
so the t set consists of all such maps
that represent spanning tree in the
graph which is
exactly rooted at 1
and the spanning tree polynomial
consists of all such monomials
the upper bound for this spanning tree
polynomial is can be computed by a
determinant of computation using matrix
theorem this was known before
[Music]
now we will see a very interesting class
of polynomial which is called set
multi-linear polynomial
consider this matrix of variables of
dimension in cross m
a set multi-linear monomial of degree n
can be constructed from this matrix by
picking exactly one variable from each
rows of this matrix
this can be interpreted as a map from
the rows of this matrix to these columns
of this matrix say this map is pi here
and the monomial can be constructed
simply in this following way
a polynomial that consists of this kind
of monomial is called statement in a
polynomial
as an example our spanning tree
polynomial is a set multi-linear
polynomial
now we are interested in proving
monotone lower bound against spanning
tree polynomial so we need a structure
theorem for set multi-linear monotone
polynomial
this is a focus structure theorem and it
has been used previously by valiant and
german steel and other authors
informally it states how to write a set
multi-linear monotone polynomial into
sum of simple monotone polynomials
formally speaking consider this variable
matrix of variables of dimension n cross
m
and say f is a set multi-linear
polynomial monotone polynomial defined
over this matrix of variables now if f
has a monotone circuit of size s then f
can be written as a sum of s many
product polynomials alpha t times beta t
with the condition that both alpha t and
beta t are monotonous set multi-linear
polynomial
the states i of alpha t and i of beta t
is a partition of the rows of this
matrix and this partition need not to be
contiguous
now
precisely alpha t is a monotone set
multi-linear polynomial defined over a
sub matrix of dimension i of size of i
of alpha t times n
with this sub matrix has rows
corresponding to elements in i of alpha
t and similarly beta t is a monotone set
multi-linear polynomial defined over a
sub matrix of this matrix
with
the rows of that sub matrix coming from
the set i of beta t
this condition is saying that size of i
of alpha t and size of i of beta t must
belongs must be in between n by three
and two n by three
this condition is called nearly balanced
partition condition
now once we have this structure theorem
let's see a general technique to prove
the lower bond
first define a monomial measure define a
measure from the monomial state to the
positive rays such that it is a
sub-additive measure
and now write f as a
sum of product polynomials now try to
show that for every i for every
polynomial the measure is low but for
the target polynomial the measure is
large and by showing this we can get a
lower bound on the size s
now using this technique will prove our
first lower bound result
in our case the measure is the count of
spanning tree monomials so first write
spanning tree polynomial as sum of
product polynomials using the structure
theorem
now observe
any product polynomial cannot generate
the non-spanning tree monomials because
once they are generated they cannot be
cancelled out because this is a monotone
computation
so having this idea on mind
using expanded mixing labor on a d
regular expanded graph we show that
there exists a constant c one such that
the no spanning tree monomials any
product polynomial a t times b t can
generate
at most c 1 times d whole to the power n
minus 1
on the other hand using matrix theorem
we show that there exists a constant c 2
such that the number of monomials in
this spanning tree polynomial is at
least c 2 times d whole to the power n
minus 1
now together these two points
by showing c 2 greater than c 1 we get
our required lower brown
now we will go to the next part of our
talk that is our second result which is
epsilon sensitive monotone lower bond
now we have very good lower bounds again
monotone computation so naturally we ask
can these monotone computations can
these smaller lower bounds give you a
general circuit lower bond
important to mention that in the boolean
world this problem has an affirmative
answer
variant gave us a special kind of
monotone function which are called slice
function and showed that if we can prove
more to lower bound against the slice
functions then we can get general
circuit lower bound
but what about the arithmetic one
rubesh in 2020 gave an approach in this
arithmetic world the approach can be
interpreted by this following problem
is there a hard polynomial f such that
for every epsilon greater than 0 this
polynomial g epsilon which is equal to e
plus epsilon times a has large monotone
complexity
here e is a polynomial which has
efficient monotone circuit
explicitly ruby showed that if if we
pick e as
one plus summation x i whole to the
power n which has a very efficient
monotone circuit then strong monotone
lower bound on g epsilon for every
sufficiently small non-negative epsilon
will imply general circuit lower bound
on f
interestingly if we want to get a
general statement in a circuit lower
bound against a we can choose this easy
polynomial as a full set multi-linear
polynomial
now some important reward regarding this
approach
first observe for epsilon equal to 0 the
polynomial g 0 has a very trivial
monotone circuit
so what ruby's approach indicates that
the hardness of polynomial f should
imply
that there is a significant
discontinuity
on the motor lower bond of g epsilon for
very small
negative epsilons
second important point here that the
polynomial g epsilon has monomial
support full
so any support based load one technique
simply fails here as an example our
previous technique where we count
the number of spanning tree monomers
will not work here
informally the reason it will not work
here because there is no notion of
forbidden monomers in this polynomial
so the only way is that the lower bound
technique must use the coefficients very
crucially and idea here is to use
techniques from communication complexity
[Music]
in 2021 the first epsilon sensitive
learnt on lower bound against a vnp
polynomial family were proven by
chattanooga dotto and
for the condition epsilon is at least 2
to the power minus omega rooted
so can you show this for people
polynomial
in this work we showed that the spanning
tree polynomial for complete graph on n
vertices requires spanning trees
exponential size epsilon sensitive
neutral lower bound in the set multinear
setting for epsilon at least 2 to the
power minus omega root n
an important remark here that our lower
bound technique crucially uses the
discrepancy measure from the
communication complexity model
so what is the communication version of
spanning tree polynomial let's see what
is the spanning tree communication
problem
the problem is do the following
a vertex say a fixed vertex set v has
been partitioned into
in between alice and bob and alice gets
va and bob gets vb
the input to this problem is a set of
edge maps
what is that so alice gets
the all the edge detection on her part
of vertices and bob gets all the edge
detection in his set of vertices
and together they want to check whether
these two sets of edges forming a
spanning tree rooted at vertex 1 or not
the vertex 1 is a fixed vertex in our
given vertex set v
for first we showed that this problem is
very hard under a fixed partition of the
vertices and we showed this by giving a
gadget reduction from this inner product
problem
the inner product problem which is a
very hard problem is defined over two
sets of variable x and y
it's simply it is a boolean function and
it computes summation i equal to 1 to n
x i times y i mod 2.
we show that
for an input instance x comma y if i p
of x y equal to 1 then our gadget graph
g x y has a spanning tree
and if i p of x equal to 0 then the
gadget graph will have a cycle
let's see what is the reduction here
we show the reduction for a twin bit
inner product problem our
gadget reduction has n plus one many
gadgets
for i equal to one to n i will define
the ith gadget
and later i will define the n plus one
with gadget
the i gadget has two alice node one in
the top one in the bottom
and two bob's done one in the top one in
the bottom
depending on the values of x i equal to
zero or one the alice nodes are
connected either to the bob norris or
bob's notes on the same gadget and
or connected to the alice node in the
next gadget
let's see how they are connected
for x i equal to 0 the top alice node in
the ith gadget is connected to the top
alice node of i plus one with gadget
similarly the bottom alice node of i
gadget is connected to the bottom list
note of i plus one with gadget
for x i equal to one the top alice note
of eighth gadget is connected to the top
bob note of it gadget
and for xa similarly the bottom alice
note of either gadget is connected to
the bottom bob's note of eighth gadget
now see how the edge direction is going
out of the bob's node depending on the
values of y eyes
for y i equal to zero the top bob's dot
of id gadget is connected to the
top and this note of i plus one with
gadget
similarly the top bob's node the bottom
box node of alice's uh of the bottom box
node of ith gadget is connected to the
bottom alice node of i plus one k j
and for y i equal to one
the bottom box node of ith gadget is
connected to the top alice node of i
plus on the gadget higher this edge
and similarly the bottom the top
box node of ith gadget is connected to
the bottom and this node of i plus one
it gadget fire this edge
now let's see what is the n plus one
with gadget
the n plus one gadget has one alice node
that is a or one alice node one bob's
node the bob's node is connected to the
root r and that alice node is connected
to the first gadget top and this node
now observe
what is happening here
for the value x i times y i equal to
zero
then two case can happen
for x i equal to zero
the alice node the top alice node is
connected to the top alice node of i
plus one with k j
similarly the bottom list node is
connected to the bottom alice node of i
plus on the gadget
but when x i equal to one but y i equal
to zero
there is a path from top and this node
of eighth gadget to the top left node of
i plus one gate higher this vertex b i
one
similarly there is a path
from bottom to this note of either
gadget the bottom at this node of i plus
one is gated higher this vertex p i two
but interesting thing happens when x i
times y i equal to one
observe there is a path from top alice
note of ith gadget
to the
bottom and is not of i plus one with
gadget so there is a change of layer
here
similarly the bottom alice node of ith
gadget is connected to the bottom either
to the top and this node of i plus 100
gadget
now for x i times y equal to 1 this
changing of layer in the paths will help
us to show
how the reduction works
so let's see let's get get an example
consider one instance of the inner
product ip that if we use a three bit
inner product and the values are x i are
all one here and y wires are all one
here
these are all the
vertices of alice and work in my gadgets
let's see
what happens to a path that starts from
a11
so there are three many three eyes such
that x i times y equal to one and three
times the path that starts from a one
one will change its layer
and if it changes layer odd many times
observe it will eventually reach
the b41 vertex
that is the
n plus 1 gadget bob's vertex
so once this path reaches this b41
vertex
it can add it can go back to the root it
can go to the root r simply
and observe any other vertex that is not
on this path
there exist there always there will
always exist a path from that vertex to
either this b for one vertex or this a
four one vertex
if it has a path to this b four one
vertex then it will already connected to
the root it is already connected to the
root
but if it has a path to the a four one
vertex then it is connected to this a11
node via this package and we already
have seen that there is a path from a11
to root
so
whenever there are odd many i's such
that x i times y i equal to 1
there is there is always a spanning tree
is forming in this gadget graph
let's see the zero instance of ip
consider this instance where x 1 equal
to 0 x 2 x 3 are 1 and y 1 y 2 y 3 are
all one
so this is these are the
vertices of alice and bob in the gadget
and just
look what is the yellow edge is going
here how is the yellow hs is going here
intuitively the path that starts from a
1 1
since there are even many i's such that
x i times y equal to 1 will change the
layer even many times
and always eventually it will reach this
node a41
generally the top alice node in n plus
one at gadget
and once it reach here
once it reaches here it will always
complete the cycle via this
package
so whenever we will get a zero instance
that is there are even many i sus that x
i times y equal to one
the path that starts from a one one will
change its layer even number of times
and it will complete the cycle by
reaching this last this stock in alice
vertex of n plus 1 gadget
and com
by
using this package
so
this completes the reduction and what we
saw that
if our inaugural distance is 1 then our
gadget graph has a spanning tree if our
inner product instance is 0 then the
gadget graph will have a cycle
now we'll come to a very important
measure which is called discrepancy
measure for the communication problem
say we have a communication problem and
this is a communication matrix of this
combination problem f the combination
matrix has rows corresponding to every
input of alice and columns corresponding
to every input of bob for it alice input
x and then bob's input y the entry x y
is
simply the value of f of x comma y
so it is a boolean matrix
now a rectangle of this matrix is a sub
matrix of this matrix such that the rows
and the columns of this sub matrix may
not be contiguous in this orange in the
original matrix
so this is a rectangle's example
and
as i mentioned with different color this
is all the end rays are zero here so
this is zero monochromatic rectangle we
say
and similarly this is a one
monochromatic rectangle but this is a
mixed rectangle
informally for a rectangle the
distribution measures how much the
rectangle is mixed
formally the discrepancy comes with a
distribution over the inputs of this
matrixes
over the entries of this matrices
and
given this distribution for a rectangle
the discrepancy measures the absolute
weighted difference the between the
zeros and ones of that rectangle
now
the discrepancy of this whole matrix is
the maximum discrepancy of the rectangle
that is appearing in this
communication matrix and the discrepancy
of this communication matrix under this
distribution data
here
is the discrepancy of this function
communication problem if
now
intuitively if the more the rectangles
are mixed the harder it is for a low
cost communication protocol to
distinguish the zeros and ones in this
matrix
so the lower the discrepancy the harder
the problem becomes
showed and gold ridge in 1988 showed
under uniform distribution the inner
product problem has discrepancy at most
2 to the power minus omega n by 2 where
size of x and size of y are in
now immediately by our reduction what we
get here is that for a fixed partition
of vertices on the set of for the fixed
partition of vertices there exists a
distribution such that the spanning tree
problem has low discrepancy
so we get the low discrepancy of
spanning tree polynomial for a fixed
partition but are we done here
no the reason comes from the structure
theorem
observed
using structure theorem we can write the
spanning tree polynomial as a sum of
product polynomials now every product
polynomial works like a rectangle
where rows of the rectangle comes from
all the monomials of alpha t which
belongs to alice
and columns of this rectangle
will come from all the monomials of beta
t which belongs to bob
and similarly they get an i of alpha t
and i of beta t which is a partition of
this n set now
for different product polynomial the
partition give may be different
that is why if the partition is changing
then to make for in order to get the
discrepancy low we need to change the
distribution also
but this is a local measure
what we need for the lower bound is a
global measure
and that we get in the following way
by a uniform distribution
we essentially got that we need we
essentially got a universal distribution
under which for every nearly balanced
partition the discrepancy of stand
standing to volume remains low
and once we have this distribution we
are able to transfer this
discrepancy bound to the lower bound
using a very novel correspondence
theorem
our universal distribution intuitively
is the following
we pick the gadget crop gx5 uniformly
and then
pick and then embed it in a bigger graph
by after permuting the vertices of the
bigger graph randomly
now
by saying using this uniform
distribution we are able to show that
the spanning tree volume has discrepancy
remain
low
the discrepancies sensitivity
correspondence theorem the theorem
states the following
consider any 0 1 set multi-linear
polynomial f
0 1 means
the coefficient of this polynomial is
either 0 or 1
now consider the natural communication
problem
cfp
with respect to this polynomial f
as an example recall for spanning tree
polynomial we introduce this
communication problem spanning tree
now if you have a universal distribution
delta
and
if you can show that the communication
problem cfp has discrepancy at most
gamma with respect to delta for every
nearly balanced partition p
then the monotone complexity of if n
comma m minus epsilon times f is at
least epsilon by 3 gamma as long as
epsilon
greater than equal to 6 comma by 1 minus
3 gamma
the polynomial if n comma m is that easy
set multi-linear polynomial that is the
full set multi-linear polynomial that we
have already described before
what it states here simply that if we
can if we have a discrepancy upper bound
like 2 to the power minus omega n
then for epsilon at least 2 to the power
minus omega root n we can get an
exponential size lower bound
and that is what we exactly got here
which construct and universal
distribution delta such that the
discrepancy of spanning tree problem
with respect to delta for every nearly
balanced partition is at most 2 to the
power minus omega n
now let me summarize our whole world
we showed the first exponential strongly
exponential separation between monotone
vb and vp
we gave the first exponential size
epsilon sensitive lower bound against a
pv polynomial
now
some open problems
find a polynomial with polynomial size
non-monotone formula but has strongly
exponential size monotone circuit
complexity
remember
our spanning tree polynomial that have
been used in that has been used in the
monotone vp versus gp separation
has an efficient abp
because of determinant computation we
still do not know if
it has any non-monotone efficient
formula
second problem is give a strongly
exponential size epsilon sensitive lower
bound the reason is our target
polynomial our target polynomial in that
epsilon sensitive lower bound
uh problem was the spanning two
polynomial for the complete graph on n
vertices which is of variable n square
and the lower bound is 2 to the power
omega n
we have more interesting open problems
for that we invite you to check our
paper
using this following link
thank you